Formula One abolished great girls you
know great goals were models wearing
kind of revealing skimpy clothes on on
the racetrack doing promotional
activities and after Formula One
abolished them some of these girls went
on Twitter lashed out at feminist they
said we lost our jobs because of you but
I think it's great it's great that
Formula One did that because in this day
and age we can no longer allow the
patriarchy to tell women what to do with
their bodies it is up to less attractive
women
oh
some of the promoters
maybe are I still need to meet that one
who is courageous and say look I want to
cancel you because I don't agree with
you but they come up with all funny
excuses and this one was like
um
yeah you were not accurate I don't mind
but you were not act because this was
the joke I I used to do I was I was I
would say you know I'm a right-wing
comedian and the downside of being a
right-wing comedian is that there's no
one else whose material I can copy you
know and he was like you implied that
you are the only right-wing comedian in
the country but there's also Andrew
Lawrence and Leo cares so okay so it
makes three of us the point is it's
still valid isn't it when Omid jalili
says I'm the only Iranian comic in the
world do they ban him because he he
claims that obviously the point is right
but anyway
so next day on his Facebook page of this
Comedy Club there was a big debate he
had a review for everybody and he gave a
bad review just for me and I thought he
was trying to be edgy but failed and I
thought you know I told you I was going
to do this and there's no need for you
to throw me under the bus so there are
debate started in this public group and
then the headliner no less of that night
comes on he had to research my real
Iranian surname and I am my my day job
my employer oh don't you work for the
BBC aren't you supposed to be impartial
isn't this your name and of course soon
enough
I was I was called to my boss's office I
can't say for sure that that was
actually you know the trigger
uh but yeah he basically outed me a
fellow comic and um one thing that
really uh
annoys me is that
a lot of times it's not even the
audience who complain it's fellow Comics
or the MC
uh who just throw you under the bus and
what do you think that is Nicholas
um I don't know because
uh being a liberal although they call
themselves liberal maybe
Envy jealousy and also
um maybe viewing comedy the way they
view any other
um activity in life as a as as people
who see themselves the lefties as
depositories of the truth right like the
Communists they have already seen the
end of times it's going to be like that
and Islam is the Same by the end
everybody will be Muslim or communist so
anything is legitimate to get rid of you
know people who don't agree with you so
it's not like okay I'm a comic I have
because this is what I like about comedy
it's the most direct form of art or
craft it's not like you do a painting
and say okay you don't you don't like it
you don't understand maybe after my
death like like Van Gogh I'll be famous
I'll be appreciated and people will say
I was ahead of my time in comedy in
stand up the reaction the judgment is
immediate so people either like you or
they don't like you and if I have bomb
if I have bombed or when I have bomb so
I have already bombed I have already got
the verdict what is the reason for you
to go and complain to The Venue owner or
to or to my day job employer
or or write a bad review about me which
even by the way doesn't doesn't uh I
know I'm putting a lot of meat on the
grill like you say in Italy but this is
another thing I did a competition I was
in the final of Natty's new Act of the
years at at
um Hackney Empire it's very prestigious
competition yeah thank you to this day
is my best result competition wise I was
in the final
uh I didn't win but I was a finalist I
have the clip and I got two Applause
breaks and an evening standard that the
reviewer says oh yeah people as soon as
right wing comic uh Nicholas DeSanto
came on stage people slumped back in
their church I have it on tape I have
two Applause breaks in in five minutes
so why why would you lie anyway you know
so to get back to your question I think
any means is
um legitimate for them just to
bring you down which which
um to put it quite concisely cancel
culture they just want to cancel you
thank you